ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
No matter
how you use Google
Cloud Platform,
we have tools to help you get
things done quickly and easily.
In this short video,
we'll cover the Cloud SDK,
the gcloud command
line, and Cloud Shell.
The Cloud Console, our
integrated web-based Google
Cloud Platform
Management web UI,
is a great place
to start using GCP.
It offers powerful
and centralized site
to manage all of your
resources, projects,
and billing information.
And you should check
out the video link below
for more details.
Next, we'll talk
about the Command Line
Developer and admin tools.
Let's start with Cloud SDK.
Cloud SDK UK is a set
of command line tools,
including gloud,
gsutil, and bq, which
you can use to access
Compute Engine, Cloud
Storage, BigQuery, and other
products from the command line.
You can run these
tools interactively
or in your automated scripts.
Cloud SDK support on
Linux, Mac OS, and Windows
and requires Python to run.
You can install via
apt-get, or yum,
or by using an installer in
interactive or non-interactive
mode.
Once installed, the SDK supports
updates and additional features
as we'll see in a minute.
We'll also talk about how not
to install Cloud SDK later
in this video.
The most used part of
Cloud SDK is gcloud.
And the typical first
command after installation
is gcloud init to
perform setup tasks.
This takes care of both
authorizing Cloud SDK
tools to use your user account
credentials to access your GCP
resources as well as setting
up a configuration, which
covers the active account,
the current project,
and optionally, the default
Compute Engine region and zone.
You can rerun this
command at a later time
to change your settings or to
create a new configuration.
You can view the
current configuration
at any time using the
gcloud config list command.
Managing and updating Cloud
SDK is also done using gcloud.
By default, the
SDK installs gcloud
commands that are
generally available or GA.
Additionally
functionality is available
as SDK components
named alpha and beta
and can be installed using the
gcloud components installed
command.
Updates to existing
components are achieved
with gcloud components update.
Once installed and
configured, you
can achieve virtually
anything with gcloud
that you can do
with Cloud Console.
In fact, when using
cloud console,
you're often able to obtain
the equivalent gcloud command
for what you are doing in
the graphical interface.
Manage VMs and storage buckets,
setup networking and firewalls,
build and test locally,
deploy to production,
and monitor logs-- it can
all be done with gcloud.
And all of this can be automated
in scripts and [INAUDIBLE] code
for CI/CD tools.
For a richer, more interactive
experience, as you type,
autocompletion is available
via an interactive mode.
Check it out.
It works with gcloud, but also
with the other command line
tools in the SDK.
For those Windows
PowerShell users
out there, do not feel
left out as we have
Cloud Tools for PowerShell.
This set of commandlets
for PowerShell
will let you manage GCP
resources in a way that
should feel familiar.
Let's now switch to Cloud Shell.
Wouldn't it be nice if you
had an always-available,
browser-based
environment with gcloud?
What if it also came with
all your favorite tools
such as Git, Bash,
build-and-package tools,
Docker, kubectl, your language
specific tools, text editors,
et cetera?
This is precisely what
Cloud Shell offers,
a temporary G1 small
virtual machine,
running a [? DBN ?]
image hosted on GCP
with all these tools
always up-to-date.
It comes with 5 gigabytes
of persistent disk
storage for your scripts,
source files, dot files,
and for your own binaries.
There's even a built in web
editor with support for Java,
Go, Python, Node, Ruby,
PHP, and .NET Core--
all of this from a
simple web browser.
Best of all, it's free.
Cloud shell can be used to
run gcloud commands only
without having to install,
update, or configure it.
Authorization to GCP projects
and resources is also built-in.
Cloud Shell can also be used
as a development environment
with its web preview mode,
which enables a browser
to access a web server
running on Cloud Shell--
App Engine's local
SDK for instance.
Cloud Shell also has
some advance features.
The boost mode option
will provide you
with a larger N1 standard
one VM instance for 24 hours,
thus enabling better
CPU and memory.
Cloud uses tmux
by default, which
is great to reconnect
to a running
session in a new browser
window, but also to split
the window into left and right
panes for debugging purposes.
Also if you'd like to
customize the environment
with additional tools, you can
provide your own Docker image.
A few additional things to know.
First, a Cloud Shell
session terminates
after one hour of inactivity.
Then any modification
that you've
done outside of
your home directory
are lost when the
instance is terminated.
Otherwise use the customization
feature that I've mentioned.
Finally, if you do not access
Cloud Shell for 120 days,
your home disk will be deleted.
With our iCloud SDK
and Cloud Shell,
you should have all the
developer and management tools
needed to go build
something awesome.
Ready.
Go.
If you'd like this
video, please like
subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward
to more GCP essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]